to kick things off here at the very end
of last month we released our studio
connect 1.9
with new features for content curation
to build your ideal showcase of data
products
and so today kelly is going to go
through a demo of the new functionality
and we'll be here to answer any and all
questions that you have
so again please feel free to use the
chat window to ask questions or i'll put
the slider link in there shortly if
there's anything you want to ask
anonymously as well
and with that i will turn it over to you
kelly
awesome thanks rachel i'm going to share
my screen here
all right
hopefully that's showing up okay for you
yep i can see it it's not in the
presentation mode yet but i can see the
slides
i'm going to be hopping
through the browser and in and out of my
rstudio
ide so i'm just going to keep it like
this it doesn't bother everybody no
that's like a percent like this it gives
like a casual feel so feel free to ask
as many questions as you want um
i also want to give a call out to katie
maciello who's on the call as well as
one of our cs reps she
took some slides that i built and built
some better slides and then i took her
slides and turned them into these slides
so katie thank you for your slides just
keep passing them back and forth and
improving
upon them forever and it will be great
uh
but thank you for that um so welcome i'm
here today to talk about our studio
connect and the release we did last
month
which was 190. it introduces uh some new
functionality and
a new
r package called connect widgets
that is the big headline
for this release
and our package actually not
not anything having to do with connect
code at all um there's a little bit of
functionality that went along with that
i'll talk about some
uh quality of life improvements for
problem to go along with this package as
part of the one i know release
but largely this is about an external
our package we produced to add some
functionality that i think was really
missing in the product itself
this is the connect widgets official hex
logo and we haven't officially made
stickers of it yet but edgar lee's put
together this hex logo uh himself for us
and so i wanted to give him a special
call out as well
but in order to level set here i want to
make sure that everybody is sort of on
the same page with us as we talk about
connect and talk about
the feature set that
connect widgets and plugs into here
when i think about connect
i am thinking you know
as a product manager across a large
number of different user profiles so
i think about what connect can do for
the admin i think about what i can do
for the data science leader what it can
do for the stakeholders and the viewers
but mostly
because of my background of data science
myself i think about what connect can do
for the publisher
and when i think about the publisher
actions that exist on connect you're
sort of thinking along four different
vectors thinking about what connect can
do for deployment
that means deploying different artifacts
and r and python
and you can choose from a number of
different deployment mechanisms you can
go
push button deployment you can deploy
python content through a cli you can
plug into your
get version control system and do get
back deployment uh or you could even
like fully customize
like scope out
a deployment pipeline using our server
api so you've got lots of different
options that take you from
the basic
getting something off of your laptop
capturing the basics of that environment
and putting it on to a shared server
all the way to like devops style
deployments the icd
um we think about execution
um you can choose between publishing
static content or publishing
uh content that's backed by the source
code itself so that you can set it up to
run on a schedule or you can control the
number of processes and connections to
that process if you have an interactive
content type like an application or an
api
i think about management i want to
control the metadata that is associated
with this individual content item
i want to be able to publish new
versions of it in place like roll them
forward backward do blue green style
deployments between
different content items i want to be
able to access the report history if i
have a scheduled report and see
you know the history of what i've been
producing over time and i want to be
able to do some light organization with
tags and track usages
for the final step
distribution i'm thinking about
actually making an impact in my
organization how am i going to get this
content that i've spent so much time
deploying and crafting and managing into
the hands of people who actually need it
sometimes it's just you who need
something or it's you your future self
who needs to be able to find something
sometimes it's a group of larger folks
who you want to distribute this thing to
you want this to be a showcase of what
you're producing for your organization
for and so it's important to be able to
make sure they can find that thing on
connect or make sure you've sent that
out and through the proper channels so
you can distribute content that was on
connect through custom emails
you can set vanity urls
there are a number of things that you
can do to distribute individual content
items today
and this makes for
like a really
great
cool experience for managing individual
content items so
i'll just go ahead and
just again so that we're level setting
make sure that everybody knows what
these features look like
at least from
the management and distribution side
so i've produced this report it's based
on like this silly toy project that i
put together called cookie cutter shop
where i was managing an etsy shop to
sell cookie cutters in the shape of the
r logo and i was selling them in some
different colors they were purple black
and red and as people were ordering them
off of the etsy shop my inventory was
yarring and then i would have to update
uh that those inventory levels and then
start printing more like a 3d printer in
each of those colors as the inventory
burned down so i was producing these
like inventory burn down charts
and like updating my inventory as they
went up and down and i was replenishing
and orders were coming in and every day
this report would run and then send me
an alert or not send an alert
based on whether the inventory level
crossed a certain low end threshold that
i wanted to trigger the action for
taking more
3d printing on
so this is my inventory control
uh report and
what i can do in connect this is
the publisher view within connect i can
control the access settings to it i can
set
just
me to be able to see it or i can open it
up so that anyone can see it on the
server
i can add collaborators so if i wanted
to add rachel and she comes on board i
hire her as like hey you're gonna keep
track of my inventory now i should
probably add you as a cooperative to
this report
so now she can come and
manage this report from these updates to
it check my code and make sure it's
correct
and i can add a link so that we can
share this report with other folks
and we don't have to share this like
ugly
long url we can make a cute short world
public
before
let's save that
and then we can distribute this whole
thing just based off of this individual
link
that's the open solo view
back to the publisher view the other
thing that's
really useful here as i mentioned is to
have this report running on a schedule
so we want this to run you know daily
every day um
at
maybe maybe six a.m that would be good
six a.m that'll be nine a.m for rachel
since i'm on the west coast she's on the
east coast
and we'll need to collaborate on this
and then i want to send a custom email
after the update but i don't want it to
send
every day i only want it to send us an
email if the inventory falls
below a certain level for a certain
color
so i've written that logic using a
flashlight package into a custom email
associated with this content item we
publish both the report and the email
together as a bundle here on connect so
now when i set
this report up to get published
and run every day
this will send an email and i have a
little screenshot of it and we'll show
you my actual email because that's a
disaster but here's what uh
a report email looks like and i have a
little banner image and it lets us know
that we need to go check the inventory
levels and everything is wonderful
so those are the basics of
managing access distribution scheduling
for report type content item there are a
couple other things that you can do here
that that not everybody takes advantage
of on the finance server one is tagging
if you want to go through and add a
level of organization to your connect
server
you can have an admin set up a tag
schema for you and as a publisher that
means that you have access to
uh all of the tags that your your
tag schema will provide so these are
hierarchical tags which means that they
work a little interesting if i want to
tag something as python content i can
then go in and tag it as a subclass of
python content so i can apply the python
tag and say the dashboard oh that
doesn't make sense for this particular
document since i wrote it in r that's
just an example of how the hierarchical
tag system works you'll see that i
tagged this as email since it has a
custom email associated with it and this
is our sales demo server we're going to
be able to find
reports that have custom emails
associated with them very quickly
so that's the basics of
uh kind of how to manage a single
content item on connect
and i think this this works like
really well for single items at least um
if you are in a scenario where today you
have connect and you only have like five
different content items and they're all
beautiful you've set down the urls for
them and they're all tagged maybe or
maybe you don't even need tags you only
have five items so everything is labeled
and maybe your stakeholders have to do a
little bit of reading they've read the
description associated metadata and
and thumbnail images with them and
everything
is
fairly discoverable
content discovery is not an issue for
you
but if you're like me
and i hope that a lot of you are because
uh i find it really exciting to build
these content items and publish them
if i start a project
it very quickly turns into like
i was trying to make a shiny application
and all of a sudden now i have like
three pins and two static documents and
a scheduled document and like a
graveyard of like old content items that
were my prototypes and i've got like an
instrumentation dashboard off to the
side that's watching the usage of this
shiny application and this project just
explodes
and
now you've got you know five or six
content items that are all part of a
single project
you're not you don't have just
one
report that's the output of your data
science work now you've got this
body of work that all needs to be
tracked
and understood as like a cohesive unit
sometimes that means like you've got
additional collaborators coming on board
and there's all of this complexity that
comes with building out data science
artifacts
and
as far as connect is concerned
making
something that
adds a layer of content discovery at
this sort of complex project level it's
not been
something we've yet taken on until
hopefully now
so
uh
i've not been the only one experiencing
this issue we have had lots of other
customers reach out to us and i wanted
to acknowledge those
those things we hear you and you really
appreciate the feedback at this level
and so this slide is all about
how much i appreciate hearing from
our customers and your feedback and
listening
to what you'd like the product to do in
the future so please keep that coming
what we've heard from customers is that
you're producing a lot of pieces of
related content and you want to share
that all with viewers but you're not
sure
how to do that now given the tools that
we've had and connect historically so
giving your stakeholders pages and
blanks is tiresome
the default connect content dashboard
isn't
polished enough to share
you want to create sort of an app
gallery or
our content gallery app store
for your content items on connect
you want to have custom landing pages
for business stakeholders or different
groups
you want to make the content dashboard
less overwhelming and
content discovery easier
the final piece
is a piece of feedback that we took
and then changed during
the design process and i want to give
you a little peek behind the curtain at
our design process and how we built out
this feature set so the final piece of
feedback we got on this was it would be
amazing if connect could automatically
generate a gallery
and that was something we really did
consider here and we decided to move in
a different direction and i hope
that
this will still satisfy
the the core sentiment of this ask
and what we built but
um it's something that we could revisit
over time at our studio we really
cherish it and and
love to think of
our users as
folks who write code
it makes us very nervous to do things
automatically for you there's lots of
magic that exists within the package
ecosystem but at the end of the day
by using the r package ecosystem python
libraries by writing things out in code
you're making
those patterns reproducible for yourself
at least
in theory but that's more reproducible
for yourself at least
so when we designed a solution to make
content discovery a little bit easier to
make these app stores or content
galleries
a reality in connect we wanted to make
that
solution as self-service as possible and
rely on
uh existing familiar connect content
types rather than produce something that
would magically pull together your
content items for you
and
make the end solution more rigid and
less reproducible than we wanted so we
wanted it to be code based we wanted to
again like i said to be built upon
familiar known connect content types
like our markdown and shiny we wanted
the end result to be still polished have
presentable defaults out of the box so
not not need or require you to do a lot
of heavy-handed css or
work on the design front to get
something that looks really great
we didn't want you to need to read the
entire connect server api
documentation book in order to figure
this out we wanted to do some light
handholding when it comes to working
with our apis
and we wanted it to be as customizable
as possible and really easy to put your
own branding on
so we produced an r package called
connect widgets that provides html
widgets and helper functions to organize
and curate your rcdu content within our
markdown document or shiny application
that's a lot of words so i'm going to
demo it um just to show you sort of
what
all of this means
let's look over here
okay so
the connect widgets package is available
on crayon you can install that packages
uh and it's already loaded yay uh so i'm
not gonna
update it but it does give me great joy
just to type out and install that
packages connect widgets because it was
a long time getting it on to crayons
that
by a string manager uh jill is sitting
there smiling about so we're really
happy to have it on fan and it's awesome
to be able to just type that out
um
well no i kicked it off anyway
um so
once you have
the package installed and voted slightly
connected
you can come over to
open a new our markdown document that's
the easiest way to get started with
connect widgets even though you can use
these components in our markdown or
shiny applications
because if you're using
a markdown you can start from a template
page so
we have a connect widgets template
available along with the packaged
and it will open up into a template
right here
that you can just knit right away and
get started with
[Music]
a second um this is my
my new favorite
trick to removing the title
having a title in our lifetime document
just
it doesn't always look awesome
i'm just leaving
you know i can do this reason
okay here we go
um
and so the first thing i do is pull out
the title
and then uh this will take you through
some intro code chats to get started
with connect widgets and you'll note
that it does also add deep fire because
one of the things that you can do with
connect widgets is pull all of the
content that you have access to on your
existing connect server
down
locally and then use
basic duplier that you're used to using
to filter that down into the subset of
content items that you actually want to
showcase on this page
so
the setup is to connect to
the connect server that you'd like
access to and the way to do that that we
recommend is setting some environment
variables so behind the scenes i've
already set up the dot environ file
to set my connect server environment
variable and the connect api key
environment variable
so both of those are already set they're
set to that sales here that i was done
before
so once i connect it's going to try to
pull down all the content items and then
create
a variable called sample content which
will just slice 50 of those content
items out for me
so
will be more things that happen below
the document uh
further down but i'm going to knit it
from here and then we can see what
is the output of each of these
component types it's like the emitted
page
all right
the first thing we get is not actually
part of the package itself it's sort of
a joke that my family could put into the
template because it's
it's a
as you can see here
a random unsplash forest image he's
calling random forest so you can
yell ahead about that joke
but each of the the components that
make up
connect widgets
are
expressed here on
this template page that you can pull out
and push different content items onto so
we're working with this sample content
group
and the first component type is called a
card so this is just a random piece of
content that was pulled off of the sales
demo server
that nick produced on august 17th he
didn't produce
he didn't add any metadata like a
description
to this content it just gave it a basic
title and then
um
and then that was it it's an api type we
can tell that from the default image and
then if we wanted to visit this piece of
content we could click through
the open content button so that's a card
that's like represents singular content
items you can put multiple cards on a
page you don't need to use the card
content type you can pull it out
and you can use something like a grid so
if you want to represent
more content
in
less space
you could choose a grid instead so this
represents
a larger number of content there's
pagination
all of these thumbnail images are
the default ones that come with the
package if you haven't set thumbnail
images for your content
they will appear as these
defaults
in gray
in each of the
grid
and card types
now
this is a special case and
i'm not able to pull down the thumbnail
images
to
my local development environment off of
the sales server most of our sales
server content does have thumbnail
images associated with this so you'll
see this difference between development
and
pushing something up to your actual
connect server if i were to publish this
content i went
back to our sales server
and i'll have that running in the
background as i keep talking about the
different
component types here
but we'll see what it looks like to
differentiate between
local development where i don't see any
of these thumbnail images and
pushing into production where the
thumbnail images
come into play
so that's the grid and card the last
content component is a table so this
is a set
uh
table of metadata you get a name a type
an owner and last updated
and you get the mini content
from your images alongside
again it's paginated
and finally there are components for
searching and filtering so this shows
against basically the same table type if
you were to add searching and filtering
to this so i can search for
content that edgar has produced
and
uh tight um let's see let's look at all
oh no we don't have any of
let's see all
hypers
pins looks like he's produced a lot of
pins
and
you can also filter by tags you can look
at all because there's access to care
bins
um searching similarly if i were to look
at
anything that says model
i just get
this content that is is named model so
the search just searches the name field
here
you can reset
back
and the searching and filtering
component can be applied to the table
or to the grid
so that's all there is for the basics of
connect widget and its components
i definitely want to talk about
theme but let's see if i can get this
first iteration of it
published connect first before we make
some changes here
it's important
kelly i can ask um a few questions that
came in on the slido
as well while it's publishing um
one of the upvoted ones is do we
actually push the output of the r
markdown knitted or the r markdown dock
itself so for example do i have to set
things up to re-knit regularly to keep
the list up to date
yep so if you wanted uh this sample
content to regenerate or if you had this
content coming off of a tag
then you would want to publish with the
source code
and then you would want to schedule
this
to the update so i could
i could run it you know
i could run it every 30 minutes to
re-update if i wanted to
and i don't recommend
running every minute
um that seems heavy-handed if you're
down to that level then you want to
probably put these component types into
a shiny application and make them
interact with them that way at least
everyone coming to a fresh session
would
see
the content of it that they should at
the beginning of their session
thank you answer the question
john feel free to to jump in if you want
to as well
oh he said thank you yep cool
okay so now you can see
what this looks like when i publish it
so this is another interesting piece
of uh i don't know
a piece of the puzzle here
is that
some of these content items i've pulled
down i don't actually have access to
and that's because
on this server
i am an administrator so
i can use connect widgets to pull down
actually the full set of content items
that exist on the server if you're a
publisher you only get to pull down the
content items that you know that you own
and that they're collaborating on
so that's something to keep in mind as
you use connect widgets
as an administrator i need to be
sort of more aware of this and more
careful because i can produce a content
item like this one
where
even i don't have access to view
the thumbnails for each of these content
types
so
for this one this is something that i
know i own and it has a nice thumbnail
image i can visit it for this one let's
see
i'm sure that nick won't mind
but i wanted to show you this is a
feature that's been added in the last
six months to connect
where we've put in a request for access
workflow
so
as actually an administrator
i don't have
the ability to send access requests i
can just add myself to content
but that action will be audited
so i can add myself as a viewer or a
collaborative piece of content if i were
logged in here as a publisher
i would
see these same
these same
options i could i could request access
as a collaborator or as a viewer but it
would send nick an email
letting him know that i had requested
and asking him to give me his
permissions
um similarly for
a viewer role and you only have the
ability to request view access since you
don't have publisher rights and it
doesn't make sense for you to be a
collaborator
okay so now you can see that we still
have a couple content items that have
the default image we have a couple of
content items that have been updated to
their existing thumbnails
and and this is a table looks the
same so the table and the search and
filter table
they look the same between development
and
their
production state on connect
but you'll see those differences for all
the content types card and bridge that
allow you to associate a thumbnail image
so that
is
connect widgets i did want to show the
theming elements too since this document
that i've produced is
is pretty boring at this point let's
quickly add a theme here so
i i'm
warning you i'm not a great designer um
but
let's see
you can use the bootswatch themes which
are really nice
[Music]
and then often what what i'll do in
addition to this is add a background of
foreground color as well so that um some
of the
the colors can like uh fill out
the background and forgot it i find that
just adding the boot swatch alone
doesn't always like satisfy my need for
enough green on the screen
and that's uh what you'll see i've done
for
some of the images that i've locked up
through the blog post
and for the logo that
rachel used to put together but this
will show you just what you can do
how these things translate into the
different components and items when you
just add a swatch thing
beyond that you can really go to town if
you want you can add as much css as you
want to this but this just shows you
what
minty will do so when it changes the
font it changes the color of the buttons
it changes the color of the highlight
text a little bit
and the
imagination
again all the boost watch things will
take in different directions but
translate into the component items
themselves and you can
turn up the knobs on that like i said by
adding background background colors to
add
more different accent colors to
your content
so that is the theme
and the other thing that i wanted to
show
was how to
take the sample content
and turn it into something that might be
actually useful to you i'm assuming that
most folks involved if you are at all
interested in this feature set you're
not going to want to pull down a random
sample of content off of your server and
then put that onto a page so if you're
interested in interacting with connect
widgets to pull down content that's
meaningful to you there are two helper
functions you provided that you should
probably know about one is by tag
so
tag let's see i don't know what the
touchscreens
i have one picked out for pythons it's
just called python
let's look so this is all the python
content we have yeah so it's just called
python so let's see what happens when i
pull down
everything with the python tag
so now sample content has 47.
we've got 47 different pieces of python
content here and
that's a lot so i'm going to filter that
down even further
by
that
and what's my name on the server i think
it's just kelly
all right so now i'm down to nine
because i've only contributed nine
pieces of python content to the sales
that's okay
we'll use that so
so now this will take the same sample
content variable but now it contains
python content that i've produced
and it'll put that into the card grading
table so let's make that
okay so here's all my python content
that's great i don't need the table
twice
i probably don't need the table at all
so i'll just take the grid
and
the card
and then
change this to
kelly's
[Music]
and then i want to change this image too
i did i need a python banner
just do
all right
nice
one dinner
okay great
all right
let's not even knit it
we'll just
just
this works
you can see
what the final
result looks like
in a minute
and in the meantime talk through the
rest of my slides
so it gives you a bit of a sense from
what connect widgets is capable of i
hope
it gives you a sense for what you can
build with projects and
in
the back end remember that you need to
provide an api key and server address is
environment variables because it is
using the our studio connect server api
to do those calls out to your server to
pull the content items down
and give you that information about the
metadata associated with each of them
and then you can apply different groups
of content to different
html
components and place them on page or an
application
and i'm hoping that this is useful to
folks not only for the case that i
described at the top of the deck
that talks about like a project that
just blows up in complexity but also as
potentially
a content hub or not knowledge
repository for a whole group of
like sort of related content items that
belong to a single group or
an objective or an apr or a team
as a single entry point for stakeholders
so if you wanted to create a really
polished showcase
for a stakeholder group that just shows
them the content items that you want
them to see and doesn't point them to
the overwhelming luge of information
that is the the connect dashboard
you could use that for this or just like
as a general purpose presentation layer
for any curated list of content items
this is another uh interpretation
of something you can do with connect
widgets for a more complex project
i'm sure some of you have seen this demo
to you by our solutions engineers or
sales team
but this is an end-to-end data science
workflow for
visualizing and predicting bike share
data oh oh the thing that i published is
now ready okay
here's my python title content um
and it looks great
very cool very cute okay
sorry about that interruption
uh
so
the
the actual dental assets that that are
that build up this
set of analyses for
the flight shared data
is built upon
a number of of our markdown documents
that do data import cleaning and model
training and produce output in the form
of several pinch data sets that get
updated on a regular basis
those then get pulled into api
prediction services built on former
and an application
for doing an assessment of model quality
over time
and then the final output is two
different fraud and development client
apps that can be rotated between each
other so all of these components make
sort of like this ecosystem belong to
this complex data science project and
you can use
connect widgets
like we've done here to sort out all of
these different
content items and make sure that
everybody who's collaborating on them
knows where to find them he knows where
all the pieces are knows that
when something breaks you can refer to
this diagram and see what else
downstream might be affected
and use this as as not only a
landing spot for everything that's been
deployed to connect for this particular
project but also link back to the github
repository itself where we manage all
the code that goes into producing all
this content
so everything is linked together
everything can be shared as a singular
showcase
and
we're hopefully we'll be saying the
amount of complexity there is to track
over time
as i mentioned there are a couple of
supporting features that i demoed that
went into some early releases of connect
that have built into this one line of
release one was the request for access
permissions that i showed
another is more streamlined publishing
so even though you still have to set the
connect server and connect api key
on the local side for local development
these will be
by default at least automatically
enabled or content that you publish to
connect that's why you've seen me be
able to publish directly these things
that i've been building locally and they
are just working on connect i don't have
to go in and set my api key or server
address again once that content item is
published so it doesn't publish in a
broken state anymore
that is very nice
uh if you are a particularly security
conscious customer your your server
admin
does have the ability to turn this
particular feature off
as well as the request for access
conditions so those are always options
for you if these are
offensive to you in some way and the
product will continue to work as it did
before
sorry rachel
oh sorry i i was just going to say while
you were talking about publishing i see
there was a question where someone asked
is there a way to pick up changes from
git
when you make new commits to some of the
included content or how does updating
one piece of content work this way
yeah absolutely so
if i
go into connect
i could um
let's see well
yeah let's uh let's change this
i think we have time
let's do this quickly so
let's see if i can
[Music]
[Music]
all right um
and then
let's see i'm gonna create a new github
repository
in my own personal github
for this content
hopefully you have
figured that out
internally
so
in this step i won't show where i'm
creating a repository in my github
you'll do that for
your own
organizational repository
[Music]
and i'm not sharing this part
okay and
[Music]
okay so now i have a new
repository the last piece that i need to
do
is to generate a manifest for this
content item so
um i would do let's see
rs connect
right manifest
and
i know i'm not gonna write content
directly
let's see
set as working directory
now i like to manifest so that it goes
into the template example directory
and then once that's written it takes a
couple seconds but it's trying to
capture
all the information about the packages
that i used and the version of water
that i'm getting
and the content itself
including
this banner image and
it's lighting up a manifest of all of
that information for me so that i can
commit it to my github repository and
then i can link that git repository to a
content item on connect i will have to
produce a new content item i can't link
the existing one that i already push
button published
to
get i have to start over
from a fresh content item
but
since i've only published once
it shouldn't be an issue for me
thanks kelly to take
a while
it takes more than ten more seconds i'll
flip over and use a different repository
that only exists
um
like that
pulled up here
just an um
another question too and and anyone from
the connect team could probably answer
this as well but i see um someone had
asked anonymously
authorization that publishers can manage
vanities exist so that publishers can
manage vanity urls
is there an upcoming feature that so
that publishers can create tags
that's a great question so glad you
asked we don't have that slated for an
upcoming release but it is something
that we
preferred a lot so
uh i am quite aware that it's a hole
that's necessary to complete this
publisher enablement story that we're
going after here
okay
you did it oh it did it okay
let me see
[Music]
also just
realizing if people want to use the
slido for other feedback like that even
if it's not a question for today that
would be awesome as well
and i can share that with the connect
team
[Music]
okay
so several minutes of waiting this
hopefully isn't
good
here uh let's see all right so now i
should have the manifest
in a git repository and now i can come
to connect here
and
publish
import from git
as a publishing option in this published
drop down
and then if it's a public repository i
can drop the git url
right here
if
you are part of an organization that
requires private repositories you're
going to need to do some extra
configuration steps to get to this point
and enable connect to interact with your
github
and that is all detailed in
configuration docs that we can send
to you
but since
we have this server rather open for
sales demo purposes you can do that
um i skipped over this you select
your
mesh here
and then it'll go in and inspect all of
the directories inside of your
repository for anything that contains a
manifest json file
so everything all of the individual
content items that you put into our
repository need to be sort of bundled
into their own directories with their
own individual manifest files you can't
just create one manifest file that
covers lots of different content items
and publish them all as one includes i
know it's been asked for but
today you still have to publish
individual content items as individual
items here with individual names
so
here
this kicks off the deployment that's
going to now be linked to that git
repository so any changes that i push to
the main branch
will be
uh reflected
via a
a new update to this content item
so if i open it right now it should look
like exactly what i showed
you produced here but if i make a change
let's see let's add a title even though
i don't like it
icon content
push
um if i come over here to the info pane
now this will automatically get picked
up that change
uh every time the connect polls get for
changes i think that happens every 15
minutes or so but aaron correct me
because i'm wrong if you know
on that
and
if you
are impatient and want to see the change
right away you can come to the info pane
here and scroll down
to where you can see that this content
was generated from git
so once you're back to the repository
and it tells you which branch is looking
at
and the directory in the repository
it's set to check for updates
periodically you can turn that behavior
off if you want to only update it
manually but
i mean the point of this is to have it
update periodically and watch that
branch so
it's nice to have if you want to see the
change that reflected it'll go out and
look for that change it says changes
were found so it kicks off a new
deployment here
and aaron confirmed in the uh chat that
it is 15 minutes kelly
[Music]
and kelly one other question i think
maybe you answered this but it was asked
ahead of time
will the contents be only ones that you
specify in the connect widget markdown
or is that including all published
content by default
so that's a good question i think it
depends on
how you yes
the question
the answer is yes but it depends you
have to be careful of how you write the
code right so if i'm writing something
that is
uh
one of these connect widgets
that pulls all of the content and then
filters by a tag like python that
includes things that
other people
have created that i am not in full
control over
and
is scheduled out to run on the schedule
you could pull in content that you
didn't tend to because other people can
add content to that tag right so you're
not in full control
of
what will end up
being
rendered
as the content item
and state if it's running on a schedule
if you're concerned about that and you
really want to make sure
that
content items that are going to appear
on the page
are exactly the ones you want at all
times
i'd recommend either
really making sure that the logic you're
using to pull in that set of content
items
is exactly what you want it to be and
other people can't throw in
content into
that funnel potentially or
you don't publish
with the source code fact or
you don't run it on the schedule and
you're just manually updating
those are your sort of options there
thanks kelly
i am i just shared the slido link again
in the chat if anybody has other final
questions too
um but one other just quick question i
have or i see someone put in kelly is
what was that syntax trick for removing
the title
so it's uh put it in the chat
oh aaron just put it there too thank you
okay thanks
awesome thank you so much kelly i i know
we're kind of getting to the top of the
hour here right to the end
perfect timing but um if it's okay to
stay on for a few more minutes if there
are any other questions
[Music]